[Applause]
[Music]
i've got the work you think of someone
who's in their 30s the body of someone
in their 20s and the mind of a boy going
through puberty what's your boyfriend's
ding-dong like it's just a normal penis
is it big no
so you worked on phoenix too
it was the most intense boat i've ever
worked on in my life but it was good
because i hate being bored and
i like to have a challenge you've got to
push me really hard to make me break if
someone says they're tired or something
like that it's like shut them up and get
into a new industry then go be like a
waitress at a nine to five cafe or
something honey your fly is always open
oh yeah
just always ready for action
do you want to know the grossest thing
i've ever done in my life so when i was
like eight i was really curious about
how poo comes out
i put my finger at my bum okay i'm out
of here
i put my finger on my bum until i felt
the bottom of the log and then i tracked
it as i came out and i was like okay so
that's like the way that poo comes out
why would you do that you naturally know
where it's coming from anyway yeah but i
wanted to feel it
like she knows she's embarrassing
herself and she doesn't care like it's
such a good quality
i'm really hoping that asia can step in
and show her how it's done so this is
your cabin this one yeah
that one sorry i've got my like
everywhere it's like one of the dirtiest
girls i've ever met i'll clean it up
you're not done with your omelette
oh
[Applause]
oh my god i'll get you some
jack tissues just been sick all over the
side there he was i guess
this is another deck down
[Applause]
he's throwing up on the deck downstairs
i feel so much better now i bet you do
and everybody else feels so much worse i
don't think anyone's sawing up on me
before it was my first time i lost my
spew virginity my spiruginity
you're moving in the duck
wow
four weeks and you're already moving it
again
this is why i avoid dating guys on the
same boat as me because you go from
meeting them to living with them
straight away
i've never lived with anyone i've dated
before and i'm still holding out on him
because
for me sex isn't enjoyable unless i've
got a true emotional connection with
them it would just be like a penis
pumping into a vagina and i can use my
own fingers for that
that's my girl
is it the right way around the stage
so she's ready before you drop it give
it a shot this is where it all started
this is where it all began you won the
crew's hearts you know that we're your
biggest fan aisha don't you know you
were in the crew mess you met such a guy
would you expect less there's something
above deck that you'd want to see to
enjoy your surprise a surprise it will
be
[Laughter]
[Music]
did i get a yes
[Music]
i just think it's like the cutest way
that anyone's ever asked me out before
like and it's so romantic
that was the cutest thing i've ever seen
i will be your girlfriend hopefully who
would say no to a veggie proposal even
though it looked like american
his boyfriend his girlfriend the
interior you guys did a great job
overall you did an amazing job the thing
is i have an expectation for service
how you did it on your last boat stays
on your last boat you're with a
different captain out what more do you
bloody want from us
we're doing our jobs and we're doing it
well like oh in the nicest way possible
these two are gone oh no oh you guys
romantically intertwined
yeah they're so cute
jake and i aren't still
[Music]
this is the first together in like years
that actually made me
want to have a boyfriend i haven't even
had sex does that mean no you know that
i really like you he said he wanted to
go back to london and i was supposed to
go see him in london but then he like
went back to his ex-girlfriend when we
were still together and then i had to
find out through watching her
instagram stories i was just like yep
[Laughter]
are you guys sharing kevin
yeah oh nice struggles go to cheeky pony
before you gotta start
i got your back i was like ballroom
dancing drop your knees and swing your
hips this way and then stand here
all right isha your turn my turn yeah
come on yay
hips are back here yep i'm gonna put my
weight slightly forward towards my toes
and i drop now watch let's see how i
just do that
all right okay
[Applause]
[Music]
hey i just want to get something off my
chest though for a second yeah earlier
when you guys were getting ready to
leave and taking group photos your hand
went from like being on rob's backpack
down to grabbing his ass
what
okay whatever are you serious i don't
remember touching his ass yeah it went
from holding his backpack then down to
like his butt i'm sorry it wouldn't it
would have just made me
being stupid yeah i agree
so i just feel like it's like mad
disrespectful and i don't know and it
kind of actually really upset me oh
sorry so
he's wearing a [ __ ] backpack that's
the only place i've got for my hand to
breathe
it's not like it's a particularly
majestic butt it's not like i'm getting
off on it actually really upset me and i
just know if it was me
in your position and you know someone's
in a relationship it's like extremely
disrespectful yeah for me it wouldn't be
like i wouldn't give a [ __ ] that for you
obviously it's like a thing so yeah i'm
sorry yeah i just think it's like
respectful if you know someone's in a
relationship but yeah yeah to you like
in my group of friends it's not really
just don't think about it
[Music]
but now that i know that you do i won't
yeah but like for me if someone like
slated my boyfriend's ass i literally
couldn't give two you know
for you but you've told me now so i
won't do it again i guess when i'm in a
relationship it's not like a
free-for-all for everybody to grab
everything
thanks ayesha
raiding beauford scale five fresh breeze
kind confident gentle always happy to
help i'm so happy to have her back on
board
[Music]
yes thank you that's exactly what we've
been talking about what were your like
hardest moments well my low was interior
not getting as much praise as they
should have
so nice to finish the season finally
with such good praise for the interior
[Applause]
[Music]
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
thank you so much enjoy your family
i'm such a notoriously positive person
in this season showed me that even i'm
human and even i'm gonna have my low
time sometimes and that that's okay now
all i have to do is get on a plane and
fly home so everything's easy breezy
from here
[Applause]
[Music]
you